we are now preparing the debate
about the basic grant
it will come back very well
the bad luck generation receives compensation
but that is of course far too little
because they missed about 14,000 euros
and now receive approximately 1400 euros back
that's about 10
and the parties that have abolished that are d66
green links and pvda
and they say yes has been a mistake
so we have to do something about it
oh must come back
great fun
very beautiful
but suppose you have a television of 500 euros
and a friend comes over
and it kicks him completely
and he says yes sorry man
I really shouldn't have
really very cunt for me
uh here you have €50
that's kind of what's happening now
that's just totally ridiculous
that must be much higher
and we are going to fight for that today